[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
hmm
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
right
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Applause]
this planet was supposed to be a fresh
start
instead we live in fear the anomaly
storms have forced us
underground running from a planet that
considers us prey
what is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
mankind might be on the back foot but we
we push forward we don't hide
we don't run we arters
welcome to the show we have a lot in
store for you today
updates on some of our most anticipated
titles new game announcements
and the world premiere of a new entry in
one of our award-winning franchises
be sure you stay tuned until the very
end to get all of today's updates
this is square enix presents now let's
pick up with more on outriders
i could smell the storm in your blood of
enoch
so what i should play at being a god
like you
i am not playing
[Music]
outriders a co-op rpg shooter set in a
dark
original sci-fi universe
created by people can fly previously
part of the epic games group
the studio is renowned for developing
world-class shooters
like bullet storm and the gears of war
series
humankind is bleeding out in the
trenches of enoch
a once beautiful planet ravaged by a
mysterious anomaly
hyper-evolving its flora and fauna to
purge the virus that is humanity
in other words you
now enoch is hell off earth
leading the colonization advance party
the outriders are devastated by an early
storm
while most of the unit is wiped out you
not only survive
but are left altered something more than
human
now with control over time space
and matter the outriders have gained
access to devastating anomaly energies
demigods strolling through the
battlefield the tables have most
definitely turned
with the anomaly flowing through their
veins outriders have split off into four
classes
each offering a different customizable
play style an extensive skill tree
that while freely respectable demands
hard choices be made
if you prefer a devious hit and run
approach the trickster's manipulation of
time and space will be to your tastes
deadly up close the trickster will
annihilate enemies with spectacular
powers
such as the temporal slice
or if death from a distance is more your
thing the technomancer combines the
anomalies powers
with technology place deadly turrets so
release climate altering
area effect weapons to take down your
foe
the devastator class is a tank in human
form
a biological sledgehammer difficult to
kill
and dangerous to be near the
devastator's control of gravity allows
for brutal
attacks such as the impale ability or
gravity jump
[Music]
finally there's the pyromancer a
medium-range class equipped to take out
multiple targets at once
you may be easy to kill at close range
but you can leech energy from crowds of
enemies or
detonate thermal bombs to tear their
flesh apart
regardless of your choice confidence is
everything on the battlegrounds of enoch
each class has its own spin on a healing
mechanic
which rewards health for performing
certain actions that reinforce the
classes play style
so get out of cover throw yourself head
first into the fray
and think aggressive the outriders
journey will take them beyond
humanity's furthest exploration of enoch
as they fight to discover the source of
a mysterious signal
from the snow-capped heights of eagle
peaks to dense
jungles and arid deserts deadly enemies
that have adapted to their environment
to wait
there's plenty to discover off the
beaten path too outriders is rich with
side quests and additional story
you may be pulled into a search and
rescue mission
drawn in to investigate a menacing cult
or
asked to track and kill hyper-evolved
creatures in the water
each quest allows you to scavenge for
new gear and weapons
to wear or trade with the duplicitous
street vendors of humanity's new
settlements
or npcs in your own convoy
and then of course there's armor and
weapon mods which allow you to further
tweak your gear with modifiers that can
have a dramatic effect on how your
abilities play out in combat
layer in a full crafting system and the
staggering depth of outrider's loot
system begins to become evident
you'll need to be fully in tune with
your gear and abilities if you expect to
survive the game's post-campaign content
expeditions with a level threshold to
take part
expeditions is only for the hardiest of
outriders
pitting you against the most lethal
adversaries enoch has to offer
considered a suicide mission by most
your journey through the hellscape of
enoch is made possible
thanks to the outriders convoy a mobile
hub which moves through the world which
can be customized with body kits
paint jobs and oh yeah the skulls of
fallen enemies
trophies from battle aren't worth much
if they can't be shown off
your convoy will accompany you as you
join a friend's game and co-op
where your achievements can get the
eyeballs they deserve
this is all just the tip of the iceberg
as the outriders travel further beyond
humanity's reaches
the strange horrific truths of enoch
begin to reveal themselves
[Music]
lara croft the iconic female action hero
burst onto the video game scene 25 years
ago with guns blazing and pickaxe in
hand
she continues to inspire new generations
today
this year marks the 25th anniversary of
tomb raider and we are so excited to
celebrate alongside fans throughout 2021
over the years lara has uncovered lost
tombs solved ingenious puzzles
survived treacherous traps and saved the
world many times over
she's also become a pop culture icon
who's inspired countless fans around the
world to embrace their adventurous side
and to just keep moving through
challenging times
we have some exciting partnership news
to celebrate lara's 25th
including the recent reveal of a tomb
raider anime series in collaboration
with netflix and legendary television
and talent updates for the next big
screen installment of tomb raider
featuring alyssia vikander
lara's also all over the gaming space
and we're working with talented teams on
crossovers for tom clancy's ghost recon
break point
and war of the visions final fantasy
brave exvius
what is the lost valley statue is also
progressing extremely well and we can't
wait to share the final paint with you
in the coming months
and we're thrilled to announce that a
tomb raider cookbook is coming later
this year from inside editions
which will allow fans to bring recipes
from lara's global adventures back home
we're also announcing today a new
digital bundle that will give the world
a chance to play lara's reboot adventure
in its entirety
the tomb raider definitive survivor
trilogy follows lara's origin from a
survivor
to the modern day tomb raider we've only
just kicked off lara's 25 year
festivities so keep an eye on our social
channels for more nostalgic content fan
celebrations and exciting surprises
throughout the year
if i don't survive
none of us will
i've come so far
i'm not turning back
get ready
what would you do
and on our way out we have one last
surprise you've seen that lara croft has
now arrived in fortnite
but that's not the end of our epic
collaboration croft manor is coming to
fortnite creative as a playable
adventure on march 23rd
alliance studios has been hard at work
on the hub and we can't wait for you to
play it next week
be sure to check out
fortnitecreativeandfortnight.com on
march 23rd to learn more
when you're on the go you don't lose
your passion for gaming
so we're bringing some of our most
popular characters and brands to mobile
here's a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
john
[Music]
greetings 426
this is a unique opportunity
you've large shoes to fill to succeed
you will need to work together and
strike
from the shadows proceed at your
discretion
good luck
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
your eyes weren't playing tricks on son
square nx montreal and taito are
collaborating on a new vision for the
space invaders brand
with an upcoming mobile game built on
innovative ar technology
and now let's take a look at a few more
delightful games from taino
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey
[Music]
let's shift our attention to marvel's
avengers we've come a long way since
launch and today
earth's mightiest heroes are launching
on playstation 5 xbox series x
and s and the team's roster is growing
avengers you finally arrived
bruce there's only the maestro now
breathing in the desolation that
surrounds you
barton i will save you from it all
[Music]
[Music]
check out this extended gameplay from
operation hawkeye future imperfect
hey hot guy long time
good to see you how's my dog doing
lucky's great i love that dog
but didn't you move out today what no
what makes you say that they said they
were movers
francis barton what great timing
do i know you watch dogs ames hired guns
surrender quietly or die
noisily you thinking what i'm thinking
this goon squad is going down
[Music]
oh that won't feel good in the morning
we've established a direct connection to
the future time bridge
i've made the necessary modifications so
uh
what's your plan i left fury in the
future when i jump back from the time
bridge
if he's alive i'm getting him out then
we can use this project omega intel to
stop the end of the world
fair enough let's find him
got eyes on the mercenaries knocking
loose kate knocking loose
uh
i require assistance
how can people live in a world like this
a memorial whatever i thought they might
have been through
it's worse all these missing people
you think they're still out there i
don't know
did you think the supreme leader hadn't
noticed you you shouldn't be here
and soon you won't be taskmaster
oh look he's an ugly washed up shield
agent in the future too
nice to know some things never change
[Music]
come on you're leaving already
and the rats run out of their holes
you're making this
far too easy yeah sure don't you survive
you're always looking out for yourself
oh
and now let's take a glimpse into some
upcoming content
[Music]
dr rappuccini i read your proposal
and i must admit i'm disappointed
you have the men you have the tech
all you need now is me
full scale invasion
so you get me the army
i'll get you the vibranium
sincerely
with me
in this next game you will take center
stage to restore balance and happiness
in a magical world
wonder world
is waiting for a hero
or two
[Music]
because the best way to save the day
[Music]
is together
[Music]
oh
[Music]
combine your powers
face your fears
[Applause]
find your balance
true happiness is an adventure
[Music]
ballon wonder world
next up the world premiere of the next
major life is strange game
when i moved to haven springs i hadn't
seen my brother gabe in years
alex it's just so good to see you again
welcome to haven this place is pretty
sweet
i'm glad you two met is this dude my
best friend and this dude
hands me the best beers alex right
i'm stuff i didn't realize that we all
knew you were coming
for the first time in years well what do
you think
i love it i really let myself believe
welcome home i don't know what to
believe now
except gabe is dead
this one's for you gabe
[Music]
hearing everyone talk about my brother
about the life he had here with all of
you
i lost the chance to have that
what happened to gabe was a senseless
tragic accident
it wasn't an accident son now is not the
time
alex are you okay
no they're definitely hiding something
what happened here havens a community
we help each other
alex be careful there's something
you should know about me
[Music]
i know what other people are feeling i
can see these
auras around them
[Music]
if they're angry or sad or afraid i feel
it too
when i focus i can't even understand why
they're feeling it
and if somebody's feeling something big
it infects me
and i lose control
[Music]
i've never told anyone
but now i can find out what's really
going on you'll need help
i've got your back
welcome to the world premiere of the
next major game in the life of strange
series
developed by deck 9 games i'm maya also
known as mxm tune
and i'm a musician and a huge life
estranged fan so i'm super excited to be
your host for today's show
if you're not familiar with the games
life the strange is a series of
standalone adventures that explore
dramatic emotional stories about regular
people
but with a stunning twist of the
supernatural
life is strange true colors features a
brand new cast
power and story so it's the perfect
place to jump in
if you're new to the series now let's
throw the spotlight over to deck 9 games
director
zach garris and erika mori the actor
behind our brand new lead
alex chen for more
life estranged true colors is the game
we at deck 9 have been working on since
2017.
it has been a real labor of love for us
we are so delighted to share it with you
today
at its heart this is a game about
empathy about how we connect to each
other
the story is driven by a complex mystery
with supernatural elements
all brought to life by an incredible
cast led by our new player character
alex played by erika mori
what i love most about alex is she's
this smart resilient young woman
who at the start of the game has already
weathered a really difficult life in the
foster care system
but she still has this hope for the
future that
somewhere she can find a place to call
home
at the invitation of her brother alex
travels to the town of haven springs
it's a fresh start framed against the
beautiful mountain vistas
sprawling lakes and colorful
architecture
a setting that embodies the promise of
every small town across
america it's her chance to start over
in a place where she can rebuild her
relationship with gabe
after eight years apart
alex
oh what's the protocol for reuniting
with your long-lost sister after eight
years
in life estranged true colors alex's
power
or curse as she calls it at the start of
the game is an unparalleled empathic
ability
the psychic power of empathy it allows
her to experience the emotions of other
characters around her
but it's also a volatile power that can
bleed into
and take over her own emotions if she's
not careful
this power is a key part of the game in
very much under your control
and there are plenty of opportunities to
use your power as you freely explore the
streets and spaces of haven springs
on her very first day in haven springs
alex meets our cast
including two new friends and potential
romantic interests
ryan and steph who fans may recognize
from life is strange before the storm
our extensive cast of characters is at
the heart of every moment of the game
and for the first time they're rendered
using full performance capture
technology
captured and animated here in-house at
deck 9.
making this the most visually advanced
entry in the series
and the true next generation of life is
strange
in life is strange true colors the
mystery surrounding gabe's death is what
ties everything together
after alex's brother dies in what
appears to be an accident
alex quickly realizes there's a larger
story behind what happened to him
and she's determined to get to the truth
it becomes clear that
only alex using her psychic power of
empathy
can uncover what really happened
we can't wait for you to experience
alex's journey
this is your chance to build your own
future for her
and for the entire town of haven springs
thanks guys and there's one more thing
i'm excited to reveal that i'm providing
alex chen's in-game singing voice
as a long-time fan of life is strange
being even a small part of this universe
and of alex means the absolute world to
me here's a short clip of alex feeling
uncertain after having a rocky start to
her first day
in hayden springs
when you were here before
[Music]
i couldn't look you in the eye
[Music]
you dress like an angel
[Music]
your skin makes me cry
you float like a feather
in a beautiful world
[Music]
i wish i was special
[Music]
you're so very special
[Music]
what the hell am i doing here
[Music]
i don't belong here
i am so excited for this game and i hope
that you're feeling the exact same way
after this first look and now the big
news that you've been waiting for
we're absolutely thrilled to announce
that the full game is coming out in
september
that's right the full game you won't
have to wait for the rest of the story
you can binge it all at once or use the
chapter breaks to take a much needed
emotional breather
you can pre-order life estranged true
colors right now on lifestrange.com
there's also one more very
special thing we've yet to reveal
we're delighted to announce that life is
strange
and life is strange before the storm
return in an all-new
remastered collection featuring enhanced
visuals and animations
[Music]
holding on to hurricanes
the life is strange remastered
collection will be available as a part
of the life is strange true colors
ultimate edition
and also available standalone later on
this year
and that's it for today thank you so
much for watching
and make sure to keep an eye on the life
is strange channels
for more
[Music]
[Music]
and our final update today comes from
the team
at luminous productions
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone i'm ella valencia today i
am
super excited to finally announce that i
play the lead character frey
in working title project affia a brand
new ip from square enix and luminous
productions
about a young woman in a beautiful yet
threatening world
the development team has been working
super super hard to create this
remarkable journey
and it's been incredibly exciting to be
a part of it frey is a character i
immediately connected with when this
project was first brought to me and i've
had
so much fun working with the team to
bring her character to life in
performance capture and voice recording
sessions
while we're not quite ready to reveal
everything today we do have a sneak peek
at a brand new scene from the game
and the final name to share so please
enjoy
hide is that a [ __ ] dragon
is it gone yes and we should leave this
place as well
why that thing out there
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us to see what's
in store from studios across square enix
but there is more to come be on the
lookout for our next square enix
presents this summer
[Music]
we rise
[Music]
so your eyes
and live right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
hello
[Music]
so
[Music]
you